i got invited to an exclusive resort
to deliver a talk about the digital
future to what i assume would be a
couple of hundred tech executives
and i was there in the green room
waiting to go on
and instead of bringing me to the stage
they brought five men into the green
room who sat around this little table
with me they were tech billionaires
and they started peppering me with these
really
binary questions like bitcoin or
ethereum
virtual reality or augmented reality i
don't know if they were taking bets or
what
and as they got more comfortable with me
they edged towards their real question
of concern
alaska
or new zealand
that's right these tech billionaires
were asking a media theorist for advice
on where to put their doomsday bunkers
we spent the rest of the hour on the
single question how do i maintain
control of my security staff after the
event
by the event they mean the thermonuclear
war or climate catastrophe or social
unrest that ends the world as we know it
and more importantly makes their money
obsolete
and i couldn't help but think these are
the wealthiest most powerful men in the
world yet they see themselves as utterly
powerless to influence the future
the best they can do is hang on for the
inevitable catastrophe and then use
their technology and money to get away
from the rest of us
and these are the winners of the digital
economy
the digital renaissance
was about the the
unbridled potential of the collective
human imagination
it spanned everything from chaos math
and quantum physics to fantasy
role-playing and the gaia hypothesis
right we believed that human beings
connected could create any future we
could imagine
and then came the dot-com boom
and the digital future became stock
futures and we used all that energy of
the digital age to pump steroids into
the already dying nasdaq stock exchange
the tech magazines told us a tsunami was
coming and only the investors who hired
the best scenario planners and futurists
would be able to survive the wave
and so the future changed from this
thing we create together in the present
to something we bet on in some kind of a
zero-sum winner takes all competition
and when things get that competitive
about the future humans are no longer
valued for our creativity
now we're just valued for our data
because they can use the data to make
predictions creativity if anything that
creates noise
that makes it harder to predict
so we ended up with a digital landscape
that really repressed creativity
repressed novelty it repressed what
makes us most human
we ended up with social media does
social media really connect people in
new interesting ways no social media is
about using our data to predict our
future behavior
or when necessary to influence our
future behavior so that we act more in
accordance with our statistical profiles
the digital economy does it like people
no if you have a business plan what are
you supposed to do get rid of all the
people human beings they want health
care they want money they want meaning
you can't scale with people
even our digital apps they don't help us
form any rapport or solidarity i mean
where's the button on the ride-hailing
app for the drivers to talk to one each
to talk to one another about their
working conditions or to unionize
even our video conferencing tools they
don't allow us to establish real rapport
however good the resolution of the video
you still can't see if somebody's irises
are opening to really take you in all of
the things that we've done to establish
rapport that we've developed over
hundreds of thousands of years of
evolution they don't work you can't see
if someone's breath is syncing up with
yours
you know so the mirror neurons never
fire the oxytocin never goes through
your body you never have that experience
of bonding with the other human being
and instead you're left like well they
agreed with me but did they really did
they really get me
and we don't we don't blame the
technology for that lack of fidelity we
blame the other person
you know even the technologies and the
digital initiatives that we have to
promote humans
are intensely anti-human at the core
you know think about the the blockchain
the blockchain is here to help us have a
great humanized economy no the
blockchain does not engender trust
between users that blockchain simply
substitutes for trust in a new
even less transparent way
or the code movement i mean education is
great we love education and it's a
wonderful idea that we want kids to be
able to get jobs in the digital future
so we'll teach them code now
but since when is education about
getting jobs
education wasn't about getting jobs
educate education was compensation for a
job well done the idea of public
education was for coal miners who would
work in the coal mines all day then
they'd come home and they should have
the dignity to be able to read a novel
and understand it or the intelligence to
be able to participate in democracy
when we make it an extension of the job
what are we really doing we're just
letting corporations really uh
externalize the cost of training their
workers
now and the worst of all really is
the humane technology movement i mean i
love these guys the former guys who used
to take the the
the algorithms from las vegas slot
machines and put them in our social
media feed so that we get addicted now
they've seen the error of their ways and
they want to make technology more humane
but when i hear the expression humane
technology i think about cage-free
chickens or something we're going to be
as humane as possible to them until we
take them to the slaughter
you know so now they're going to let
these technologies be as humane as
possible as long as they extract enough
data and extract enough money from us to
please their shareholders
now meanwhile the shareholders for their
part they're just thinking i need to
earn enough money now so i can insulate
myself from the world that i'm creating
by earning money in this way
you know no matter how many vr goggles
they they slap on their faces in
whatever fantasy world they go into they
can't externalize the slavery and
pollution that was caused through the
manufacture of the very device
it reminds me of of thomas jefferson's
dumbwaiter you know we like to think
that he made the dumbwaiter in order to
spare his slaves all that labor of
carrying the food up to the dining room
for the people to eat that's not what it
was for it wasn't for the slaves it was
for thomas jefferson and his dinner
guests so they didn't have to see the
slave bringing the food up the food just
arrived magically like it was coming out
of a star trek replicator
it's part of an ethos that says
human beings are the problem and
technology is the solution
we can't think that way anymore we have
to stop using technology to optimize
human beings for the market and stop and
start optimizing technology for the
human future
but that's a really hard argument to
make these days because humans are not
popular beings
i talked about this in front of an
environmentalist just the other day and
she said why are you defending humans
humans destroyed the planet
they deserve to go extinct
even our popular media hates humans i
mean watch television all the sci-fi
shows are about how robots are better
than nicer than people
even zombie shows what is every zombie
show about some person looking at the
horizon at some zombie going by and they
zoom in on the person and you see the
person's face and you know what they're
thinking what's really the difference
between that zombie and me
he walks i walk he eats i eat he kills i
kill
but he's a zombie at least you're aware
of it if we are actually having trouble
distinguishing ourselves from zombies we
have a pretty big problem going on
and don't even get me started on the
transunists
i was on a panel with a transhumanist
denise going on about the singularity oh
the day is going to come really soon
when computers are smarter than people
and the only option for people at that
point is to pass the evolutionary torch
to our successor and fade into the
background maybe it best upload your
consciousness to a silicon chip and
accept your extinction
and i said no
human beings are special we can embrace
ambiguity we understand paradox we're
conscious we're weird we're quirky there
should be a place for humans in the
digital future
and he said oh rushkoff you're just
saying that because you're a human
as if it's hubris
but okay i'm on team human
now that was the original insight of the
digital age
that being human is a team sport
evolution's a collaborative act
even the trees in the forest they're not
all in competition with each other
they're connected with a vast network of
roots and and mushrooms that let them
communicate with one another and pass
nutrients back and forth
if human beings are the most evolved
species it's because we have the most
evolved ways of collaborating and
communicating we have language we have
technology
it's funny i used to be the guy
who talked about the digital future for
people who hadn't yet experienced
anything digital
and now i feel like i'm the last guy who
remembers what life was like before
digital technology
it's not a matter of rejecting the
digital or rejecting the technological
it's a matter of retrieving the values
that we're in danger of leaving behind
and then embedding them in the digital
infrastructure for the future
and that's not rocket science
that's as simple as making a social
network that instead of teaching us to
see people as adversaries it teaches us
to see our adversaries as people
it means creating an economy that
doesn't favor a platform monopoly that
wants to extract all the value out of
people and places but one that promotes
the circulation of value through a
community and allows us to establish
platform cooperatives that distribute
ownership as wide as possible
it means building platforms that don't
repress our creativity and novelty in
the name of prediction but actually
promote creativity and novelty so that
we can come up with some of the
solutions to actually get ourselves out
of the mess that we're in
now instead of trying to earn enough
money to insulate ourselves from the
world we're creating why don't we spend
that time and energy making the world a
place that we don't feel the need to
escape from
but there is no escape there's only one
thing going on here
please don't leave
join us
we may not be perfect but whatever
happens at least you won't be alone
join team human
find the others
together let's make the future that we
always wanted
oh and those those tech billionaires who
wanted to know how to maintain control
of their security force after the
apocalypse you know what i told them
start treating those people with love
and respect right now
maybe you won't have an apocalypse to
worry about
thank you